I became an actor by accident not by
design my father was a poet rather
famous American beatnik poet Lawrence
Lipton my mother was teacher and I was
taught to read at the age of one and a
half hard to believe my mother finally
convinced me that it was so showed me
evidence and I was writing epic poetry
by the age of three terrible poetry
which I dictated my father would
scrupulously note and by the time I was
twelve I'd written three novels i
mentioned that only because my father
was a famous eccentric beatnik all of
that he also left when I was very young
and since my father was a poet my mother
a teacher we didn't exactly wallow and
money and once he was gone there was
nothing so as tough times the point of
that is that I associated my father's
profession with my father's behavior and
as a result I ran as far away from it as
possible that said when I went to school
I my intention was to be a lawyer I
attended university that was still the
clear intention i was going to be a
lawyer why because it was as far as i
could get from my father's antics and
world I thought that the world of the
Arts probably led people into the kind
of behavior that i had seen with him and
that had resulted in a lot of hard times
from our mother in maine so that was the
intention however since we didn't have
any money i had to work from the age of
13 I worked an assortment of jobs one of
the things that I liked to do was acting
in school the way one would in high
school and I was a member of the
Catholic theater in Detroit which was a
very good theater group and I
stood there and one night someone came
backstage and said to me you know you
could you could earn a living as an
actor you you're you're good enough and
at that time I was a copy boy at the
Detroit times and I said well you think
that not immediately but in time I might
possibly earn as much as an actor as i'm
currently earning as a copy boy at the
detroit times and he said yes i think
you could count on that so I became a
professional actor in Detroit and I was
able to earn some money it was a good
job because it permitted me to study it
fit perfect they was school and I could
in high school and then subsequently in
college I was able to earn money which
supported my mother and me she was
working as well and I could I and I
could go to go to school I was all I
cared about I was going to going to be a
lawyer I was not going to be a poet I
was not going to write I'd stopped
writing at the age of 18 I'd written
incessantly before that I read of course
because I was in university but I wasn't
going to write I wasn't going to do any
of those dangerous things I was going to
be a stolid bourgeois lawyer and then I
decided to come to New York to finish my
education and to get the law degree I
arrived in New York looked around me and
this was a time when New York was
teeming with great teachers of acting
stella adler sandy Meisner robert lewis
harold clurman Lee Strasberg the Actors
Studio was flourishing and many of the
actors that we remember with great
admiration we're living in New York in
those days working the theater at night
studying a diet and in the daytime and
this was before the exodus Los Angeles
when television moved out there for real
estate reasons and then the actors
followed of course but at that time it
was the goal
Age of American acting education I
looked around me and I thought well if
I'm going to continue to support my
schooling and my mother and me she had
moved to New York and she was working
but still I had to work and if I'm going
to earn a living at all in this I'm
going to have to compete and it's a very
very fast track and so I started looking
around and one day I walked into a room
and there was a woman flamboyant dyed
blonde hair centaurian voice grand
gestures a grand am in short her name is
Stella Adler she talked me for a while
and asked why I wanted to study with her
and I told her that I had to earn a
living and that I I wanted to do it as
well as I could I just I didn't like
amateurism in anybody else and certainly
not myself and I would like to learn how
to act really learn how to act and from
everything i had read to heard she was
the teacher i would like to study with
she took me i studied with her two and a
half years her course was two years she
asked me to stay an additional six
months as a sister when I finished the
course but about six months into it it
was full time I woke up one morning
looked in the mirror and said who the
hell are you kidding you don't want to
be a lawyer never didn't want to be a
lawyer this is what you would like to do
and so it began I embarked on nearly 12
years of full-time education I studied
two and a half years with stella adler
four years with harold clurman to whom
she had been married he was a founder of
the group theatre and two years with
Robert Lewis also out of the group
theatre I studied modern dance with Anya
home and Alvin Nikolai I then went on to
study classical ballet with ella de
carnaval I'd I studied cicchetti
technique with her and then Russian
technique with Ben arc Harvey it came
upon me incrementally
and finally I was clearly for better for
worse going to devote my life to these
arts